uh i think we have joining us now newt
gingrich we had him on for other topics
but i want to get
his reaction what's unfolding here
tonight we have a problem now
mr speaker around the country and it's
in your old state of georgia it's in
virginia it's in new mexico it's in
minneapolis
it's in los angeles we've been watching
what happened all last summer
and now we see what's unfolding here
tonight and get your reaction and how to
best solve these problems
one of the things that shocked me over
the summer was the utter denial of the
news media joe biden never mentioned the
writing
uh that took place all last summer we
had 3 000 cops injured
during that time the tension is never
higher seems in my lifetime than it is
now
well i think that the danger we've got
which we've had before i mean
the black panther movement in the late
60s for example
engaged in fairly large-scale rioting
there were 2500 bombs
that went off in the period of 1969 to
70.
there were riots in an amazing number of
cities
in the 1960s and part of what you have
here is
that the society can't decide whether or
not it favors
law and order in the classic sense that
if you look at what's happening around
the country now
uh the forces of disorder the forces of
crime
the forces who have contempt for
civilization
are all now dominant so you have them
taunting the police attacking the police
we've made being a policeman
dramatically more dangerous
and historically that's very unhealthy
i mean historically yes there has to be
training
yes you have to look into incidents
where things occur that are wrong
but the bias historically is that the
person willing to risk his or her life
to protect you deserves the benefit of
the doubt
and deserves the support of the
community
deserves people in the community saying
we're not going to let a bunch of
thugs take your life or beat you
up or humiliate you and
all of that has now broken down and i
think that it's
a very dangerous time for the country
and one which to some extent reminds me
of the 1970s
and the whole period of clint eastwood
and dirty harry and make my day
and a series of movies where people were
so fed up with the crime
that they were in effect willing to go
and eat their popcorn and applaud
somebody
including policemen who were clearly
breaking the law
to reestablish order and i think this is
a very dangerous time for the country
and we need to understand that the more
we weaken the police
the greater the likelihood of really
serious crime
and the greater the likelihood that
innocent people
are going to be killed or hurt let me
play a
tape we played it in my opening
monologue
and i could play tapes from over the
summer i mean
you had police being attacked and doused
with water in new york city
i mean they cut a billion dollars from
the nypd mr speaker
the city's never been less safe as a
result and you could see it in the
homicide rate skyrocketing like it is in
many big cities
um there is another side of the story so
far this year we've lost
over 100 cops that have been shot in the
line of duty that's a lot of cops
and and listen listen to the taunting of
police
in a car and this is just a small
portion of it
and and taking images of a pig and
putting it on the cop car we can play
that
and thank you even the people who want
to see you here
i mean and this went on for you know
minutes
just harassing taunting sean
the question the question that has to be
asked
which was true all of last year and it's
where the left ultimately
will be repudiated by the country is
if you've got this guy on video
you know who he is you know that he was
out there
deliberately harassing and taunting a
policeman why isn't he arrested
why isn't he facing jail time i mean if
you're if we're going to back off
and we're going to apologize and we're
going to allow
the forces of crime and the forces of
hostility
to dominate the street then we're going
to get what we're now getting which is
in every major city
i think literally every major city a
dramatic rise in crime
and who does that hurt it hurts the
innocent it hurts minorities
i mean who are the largest number of
victims
of these kind of criminals they're
african-americans
so when you start talking about crime
you're really talking about
entire populations of people in chicago
in new york and baltimore
who are faced with losing their lives
potentially
not being able to be safe sending their
child out for an ice cream cone
this is madness and at some point the
society has to get a grip on itself
and decide that we're in favor of the
law we're in favor of the police
we're in favor yes yes they've got to be
trained yes
when something goes wrong it has to be
investigated
but on balance a strong effective
trained police force
is better for the poorest people and
better for the minority groups
than any other situation and we need to
get back to that and realize that
this fantasy liberalism is putting
everybody's life at risk
yeah mr speaker uh we'll bring you back
we had other topics to talk about
tonight obviously with the breaking news
uh that changed a lot of things thank
you for being with